along with behind-the-scenes features in
the occasional Marvel one-shot the gag
reels are a favorite staple of Marvel
blu-ray releases fans not only get to
laugh but we also see the bonds form
behind the scenes and it's hard not to
fall in love with them just a little bit
here are some of the most hilarious
bloopers and gags waiting on the thor
ragnarok blu-ray butterfingers one of
Milner's amazing properties is that when
thor wills it back to his hand it comes
straight away even if the hammer needs
to cross nation's galaxies or dr.
Strange's entire collection of sorcerer
artifacts Neal near always comes home
unfortunately Neal nears fantastic
abilities are one thing and the
properties of thor ragnarok props or
another the blu-rays gag reel proves
that either someone off-camera wasn't
very good at throwing or the cast just
isn't very good at catching this kind of
thing is to be expected by all
appearances
Chris Hemsworth has never been able to
catch anything anyway low blows Thor
Ragnarok included some fantastic leading
female characters Cate Blanchet turned
in a fun and utterly vicious portrayal
of the lead villain and Tessa Thompson
was funny believable and badass is
Valkyrie is mine
[Music]
and that just makes the number of crotch
shots that happen during filming even
more fitting especially since almost all
of them come unintentionally from
Blanchette Thompson or Thompson stunt
double
Ubu you may be familiar with the story
that while filming lightsaber duels in
the Star Wars prequels even McGregor had
to make an effort not to make his own
lightsaber sounds to begin with it was
quite difficult not to make the sound
yeah because it makes that nice Shh
noise when it goes down well apparently
it's not as uncommon as you'd think the
Ragnarok gag reel shows us a number of
shots when Kate Blanchet had to stop
because she realized she was making
comic book sound effects should make the
noises warm up not everything on the gag
reel is a blooper sometimes perfectly
reasonable things like warming up
between tapes just looks funny John
they're not playing to the camera or
making any funny mistakes they're just
making sure they don't pull a hamstring
when they pretend to be super people for
a couple of minutes no harm in that all
fall down maybe it's a side effect of
the revenge errs escape from Sekar
through the devil's anus or maybe
director Taika Waititi took the
bottomless mug of beer from the Doctor
Strange scene and passed it around the
cast and crew every day but for whatever
reason no one in the cast of Thor
Ragnarok seemed to be able to stay
upright for more than a few seconds at a
time
[Music]
what makes the various spills that much
funnier is that it never seems like
there's anything in particular knocking
them down they don't seem to be in the
middle of complicated action sequences
they just fall down a lot avenging Bros
while Chris Hemsworth and Mark Ruffalo
don't have the same chemistry going as
Iron Man and Hulk did in the Avengers
they've got their own buddy feel in Thor
Ragnarok though it's definitely more odd
couple' almost two years before the
film's release
Mark Ruffalo compared the Thor Hulk
relationship and Ragnarok to the one
between Robert De Niro and Charles
Grodin in 1988 s midnight run it's a
love-hate relationship but the two still
share some hilarious moments in the gag
reel unique skill the Grand Master of
the comics isn't a particularly fun guy
unless you think fun is too habitually
kidnaps superheroes to make them fight
for your amusement
regardless Jeff Goldblum's realization
of the character is one of the best
reasons to see Ragnarok you're
officially pardoned from life and when
he shows up in the gag reel he
definitely leaves an impression most
notably when he demonstrates his
real-life superpower watch this
[Music]
dancing fools most of the Marvel gag
reels feature bits of the cast breaking
into dance while filming and the reel
for Thor Ragnarok is no exception
but while the cast occasionally cut a
rug the fanciest feet on the set
undoubtedly belong to director Taika
Waititi who apparently never stops
dancing down the set working with tyka
involves hijinks dancing day is just a
big kid in the end all that playtime
translated into an incredibly fun movie
so maybe take a ytt is onto something
that is how you make movies thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to